.
AND I TRIED TO LIKE ENJOY THAT
MOMENT, YOU KNOW.
AND SOMETIMES YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE
A BLOCK OR A THREE OR WHATEVER.
BUT FOR ME, THE WAY I PLAY, THE
WAY I WANT TO PLAY MOVING
FORWARD, I WANT TO ENJOY EVERY
SINGLE MOMENT OF THAT WAS A
MOMENT I FELT LIKE OUR TEAM WAS
TURNING AROUND AND WE WERE
GETTING THE MOMENTUM OF THE BIG
SHOTS.
IT FELT GOOD.
SO YEAH.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, IT FELT
GOOD.
THE WAY WE WERE PLAYING FELT
GOOD AT THE TIME.
>> HERE IN THE CENTER.
>> GIANNIS THIS WAS THE SECOND
GAME IN A ROW YOU WENT OUT EARLY
IN THE FIRST QUARTER.
I'M CURIOUS.
GIANNIS: HOW DO YOU SAY IT
POLITELY?
I WENT TO TAKE A TINKLE?
YEAH.
WENT TO TAKE A TINKLE AND CAME
BACK.
THAT'S POLITE RIGHT?
TINKLE.